it's too difficult to evict tenants who
don't pay the rent we need more support
correct we're in a cost of living crisis
a lot of landlords that can't afford to
have tenants that don't pay them any
rent and now not only are they not
making any money but they're actually
losing money because they're starting to
pay the mortgage summarily you're okay
going to sleep at night yes knowing that
you have evicted a family and put them
out at risk of homelessness under the
street you're okay with that yes here's
what irritates me right what irritates
me is when tenants tell me they can't
pay rent because their mom just
they would never call their energy
provider and say I can't pay my energy
bill because my mom they would never
call Sainsbury's and go in and say my
mom can have free food why don't they
come to me they pray and leech and use
emotional manipulation on struggling
landlords with stories of why they can't
pay the rent
and it's wrong so you're telling me that
tenants are the ones who are praying and
leaching on correct correct